we have been sort of toying with the
idea of changing the david pakman show
opening theme song on the basis of
remixes made from a voicemail we
received so let me set this back up for
you we received the following voicemail
a few weeks ago the David Pakman show
it's my favorite show you do more good
than you know the David Pakman show
[Music]
right so that really will put you in a
good mood if you are not in one every
single day that you hear that so we took
that and we offered it to the audience
and said if you want to remix that
submit it to us and we will consider a
theme song change if there are some
really good ones I played six options
for you on Monday voting has been fast
and furious and the results of the poll
are people want us to keep the existing
theme song 29% of the audience says do
not change the theme song 24% of the
audience says replace it with option
number four which I'll play for you in a
second option number five getting 17% of
the vote and some of the other options
really not doing well at all
0% for option number six which is sad
funniest comment was that option number
four made me consider dropping some
Molly so we are going to keep the theme
song that we have but we are going to
use these new options as music before my
live stream start on twitch and YouTube
I actually did that earlier this week
during one of my twitch streams just a
reminder the most popular of the remixes
was option number four from three lawn
and the chosen masters take a listen to
this one
[Applause]
it's my favorite oh no what was that you
know exactly show it's my favorite show
okay so it goes on from there that was
the most popular of the options number
two was I'm sorry the second most
popular that's a confusing way to say it
the second most popular remix was option
number five by someone known to me only
as sorry for bat English take a listen
to that one
[Music]
my favorite my favorite show
[Music]
[Applause]
right so in any case those were the two
most popular but the verdict is we are
not changing the david pakman show theme
song some of the more common complaints
were David anything that says you do
more good than you know in your own
theme song is extraordinarily
narcissistic and you shouldn't do that
didn't even occur to me because I was
having such a good time with the songs
another one was you really shouldn't
have lyrics in the opening theme and
another one was listen if I send the
show to someone and one of those are the
opening theme songs it's just not going
to seem as credible of a show as with
what you have now and what's funny is
when we switch the theme song to what it
is now it was like 90 percent disliked
90 percent of the messages I got about
it where this is terrible huge mistake
your show is going to lose all
credibility and of course the show is
like tripled in size under the current
theme song so I will go with the
audience and I will not change the theme
song but sometimes I have to make a call
these are difficult calls to make
because the audience generally is just
averse to change but sometimes even if
the audience doesn't want to change I
have to make it and so far those
decisions have worked out pretty well in
the past but the no change vote wins
this one let me know your reaction let
me know your level of devastation about
this decision on Twitter I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman we've got a great program
planned for you today and I'm very glad
you're with us on this Friday